what I want to do in this video is dig a
little bit deeper into the deficit and
just so that you can get the data
yourself they're all available at this
at this document which is which is
hosted by the Department of Treasury so
you know that I'm not making up these
numbers but just to review that the
deficit is really a measure of how much
you are overspending in any given year
and so if you look at the deficit and
I'm going to focus on 2010 in this video
in 2010 the government spent so the
spending for the government in 2010 was
about three point five to three point
six trillion dollars and it brought in
in mainly tax revenues but it has a few
other sources but mainly tax revenues it
brought in about 2.2 trillion dollars so
based on this the overspending or the
amount of money beyond which the or the
amount of spending beyond the revenues
or the deficit the deficit in 2010 was
1.3 trillion dollars what I want to be
clear on is this is only one way to
account for spending versus revenues and
this is not the way that most companies
would primarily report their own income
over the course of the year or their own
cost or their own loss over the course
of the year most companies would not
just have to account for their cash
outlays and that's all we're considering
in this three point five three point to
three point six trillion dollars a
traditional company would also have to
include any other liabilities or any
other obligations they're taking on for
example if I hire you and I promise to
pay you fifty thousand dollars over the
course of the next year and I'm going to
pay them to you in cash but I also
promise that when you retire I'm going
to pay you ten thousand I'm going to
give you a ten thousand dollar per year
pension and on a traditional income
statement I would not just expense the
fifty thousand dollars
I would I would definitely put that in
my expenses and the government would put
that in their expenses but I would also
have to account for this liability that
I'm taking on I would also have to say
look in order for me to be able to
afford a ten thousand dollar pension at
some future date I have to make some
estimates about when you would retire
and how long you would live and what
what interest I could get on money in
all of the rest but I would have to say
I would have to set aside some amount of
money so that in the future I can meet
that obligation so maybe I have to set
aside
two thousand dollars this year and hope
it grows properly over over the course
of the next 20 30 years until you retire
so that I can afford to pay you that
much who knows but I would also have to
account for it right here that extra
liability the government in the
calculation of the deficit does not
account for that extra liability and it
is taking on other liabilities it is
making these pension promises to
government employees it has obligations
to to the veterans and Veterans Affairs
and all of that and that is not taken
account or that is not accounted for in
the deficit it is accounted for in the
gross costs and you see here we said
when when we look at just the debt the
budget we're talking three point five to
three point six trillion dollars that's
direct cash outlays or mostly direct
cash outlays if you include all of this
other stuff then it balloons to four
point five trillion dollars four point
five trillion dollars so in previous
video I mentioned that the government
right now for every dollar that it's
spending it has to borrow 40 cents of
that dollar but if you really think
about the total obligations that it has
and the total obligations being four
point five trillion took on view that
way it only has about half of that it
only has about half of that coming in in
revenue so every dollar in revenue the
government is taking on an equal amount
of obligations that year some of that is
going to express itself in terms of
increased debt and some of that is just
going to show up as increased
obligations and you can see both of
those things are increasing year after
year after year and depending on who you
talk to which side of the political
spectrum some people will blame it on
bush they'll say look at this the you
know the spending increased under Obama
which someone on the right would say but
then someone on the Left would say yes
but the spending increase because we
have to do all these bailouts the
economy went into the started to tank at
the you know at the end of 2008 we had
to do all of these emergency things as
soon as the economy tanks you
automatically the deficit position gets
worse because you bring in less revenue
and you not only do you bring in less
revenue because corporate profits are
down fewer people are employed people
start earning less but you also have
higher expenses because all of these
automatic obligations kick into effect
unemployment benefits of Social Security
benefits Medicare benefits those
increase
deficits naturally get worse but the
whole point here is to say regardless of
what party you're on things are getting
worse and they don't seem to be getting
better and generally you'll always see
this net operating cost sometimes the
net operating costs will look lower than
the actual deficit like it did in 2008
and that's because there would be some
type of actuarial or accounting re
estimate of the future obligations maybe
the pension obligations or whatever but
in most years we're taking on more
obligations than just our cash outlays
and that's why you see the operating
costs so much higher than just just the
the pure deficit right over here and
this chart right over here actually goes
into what some of those what the
difference is the actual difference and
you see that it's mainly things like
liabilities for veterans compensation
military and civilian employee benefits
government-sponsored enterprises there's
some downward revision of the tarp let
me I don't think you can see that so all
of a sudden you realize that the tarp is
going to cost us more in the future than
you thought it was going to be even
though you don't spend that 86 billion
this year you realize that you have an
86 billion higher obligation and so if
you add all of these or you say I guess
you subtract all of these from the
budget deficit then you're going to get
the net operating cost and that might
you might already find that depressing
but the point of this video is actually
that's that's just the beginning
because if you look at where we're going
the trajectory it gets even more
depressing because not only do we have
this huge budget deficit or these you
know this this huge operating cost these
this this is this law so I guess you
could say on an annual basis but it's
going to get worse and it's going to get
worse not just from the overspending not
just from the overspending on the
government programs and defense and all
of that but because our debt is
increasing so much that the interest the
amount we spent on interest is only
going to increase and that just makes
matters worse the more you spend on
interest the larger your deficits the
larger deficits the more you have to
borrow the more you have to spend on
interest and this is a long timeline
right here goes out to 2080 but it's
pretty clear that's something something
is going to give so as a percentage of
GDP the the government the size of the
government has historically been around
this you know depending on different
periods in history but in the recent
past it's been in the 20% range but if
you just let things go the way they're
going to go and a lot of these are kind
of mandatory spending things we've
already
gated ourselves tour where we think
we've obligated ourselves to it looks
like the size of the government's really
just going to take over the economy it's
going to grow over the next 20 30 years
to 30% 35% 40% of the entire economy now
if that by itself is not scary or
depressing enough for you then we just
have to look at this chart right over
here and we've already gone over some of
this chart this is the gross cost this
is the total amount we're spending
outlays cash outlays and other
obligations we're taking on and
accounting for it in some way in the
present and then you have the taxes
you're bringing in and you see this is
your net operating cost that we
calculated already and then it shows
your assets the assets of the government
mainly buildings and land and things
like that the government has a lot of
nice land and buildings and then you
also see and property plant and
equipment and all that aircraft carriers
whatever whatever you want to throw into
the mix right over here but then you see
the debt and we there's been a lot of
talk of the debt but you might be saying
wait even in 2010 didn't you know right
now as we hit the debt ceiling we have
like fourteen point three trillion but
didn't we have like 13 points something
trillion in debt in 2010 why does this
only say 9 trillion that's because we
had another four trillion in debt that
is not held by the public this is just
debt held by the public we have and that
public includes things like foreign
governments but there's another four
trillion that is held by the government
itself so that is not accounted for and
that four trillion is mainly excess
funds from the Social Security trust
that are all invested in Treasuries but
the government in the end of the day is
responsible for the Social Security
trust and so it is not accounted for
right over here so you have nine
trillion there you have another six
trillion that is seldom talked about
which is benefits for federal employees
and veterans that that's right over here
so huge obligation so a total of 16
trillion in liabilities now if that by
itself doesn't scare you enough or
doesn't depress you enough we just have
to go down a few lines on this statement
and you'll see something that does and
this right here is the expected or the
present value of the of the obligations
for Social Insurance and the way they
talk about Social Security social
insurance it's both Social Security and
things like Medicare so these obvious
these things that we've promised we
would pay to people in the future at
least that
we've told people that we will pay them
in the future and the present value and
the easiest way to think about present
value and I've done videos that go into
a little bit more depth on that is how
much money given some assumptions if you
assume that if I put money aside and
that money grows at some rate how much
money would I have to put aside in order
to fund those obligations and this value
is over the next 75 years and I want to
make it clean my co seventy-five years
that's of course it's going to be a huge
number but remember we're assuming that
we can we can grow money we're assuming
that obligations that are 75 years from
now that if I have to pay someone $10 75
years from now I don't have to put $10
aside I might only have to put 50 cents
or $1 aside and assume that that 50
Center dollar will grow by some
percentage so that by the time 75 years
go by I actually have that $10 so this
isn't the this this is actually a
discounted value this is assuming that
the money you that you could set aside
today that the obligation today that it
would grow to actually fulfill the
actual amount that you have to pay and
this should scare you these are huge
numbers this close group are what they
call the current participants and we
could read the footnotes includes
current participants receiving and/or
our eligible receive benefits for the
Social Security and Medicare programs
ages 15 and over at the start of the 75
year projection period so that's 43
trillion then open group they have
current and future participants this is
slightly lower because it's including
people who are going to be paying into
the program and not necessarily taking
out of the program but it's still a huge
huge liability it's twice as big as the
official liabilities that the government
takes on